Boom. What was the original
pronunciation? Well,
standing is back in the old days,
it was Sam the butcher and Joe the barber,
and, and my great grandfather was a
husband, which is a singer of holy songs,
like cantor would be the term now.
And when my grandfather
came to Ellis island,
he didn't speak English and
they wrote it up as h a s s a n.
And so I've lived my life
being thought of as an Arab,
being persecuted at times by Jews.
I'm actually Jewish and I
belonged to the persecuted you.
I've had experiences
where people made yes,
your name because of the spelling of
my name. Let them, hey, you asshole,
I'm one of you. Well first they'd
say, you know, being a bigot.
And then I'd say, by the way, I'm Jewish.
And what did they say? I'm so sorry.
They would look at me and then they'd say,
you don't look Sephardic.
I'm on Ashkenazi. But uh,
anyway, it's, you know,
like act with some dignity and
compassion and kindness. Yeah.
Especially for no reason. It's not like
you did something antisemetic right.
The first time I was actually physically
assaulted was during the six day war
back in the 60s when I was in elementary
school and on a stairwell in Queens,
New York. You were assaulted
because of your ethnicity?
I was assaulted by Jews who thought I
was an Arab. Jesus Christ. And they,
they attacked me and I threw them down.
I grew up,
I grew up in my father's
hardware business,
so I kind of like knew how to pick up
a hundred pound bags of rock salt and
stuff. So they like fell on
the floor. And then I said,
you schmuck some Jewish.
I like how you schmuck that way.
No, he's in Judaism. Sort of a cult.
So let me just explain what
Steve Does. Anyway. Steve
Hassan. Hassan. Hassan. Hassan.
Hassan. Yes. Yes. Um, you,
you, you wrote a book, um,
combating cult mind control.
I got ahold of you because of my friend
Nate quarry who used to fight for the
UFC and a, he is one who, uh, uh,
connected me to you.
And uh,
he was a Jehovah's Witness for Awhile
and, uh, grew up in it. Yes. Yes,
he did.
And he wrote me a really interesting
email about the mind control process of
that.
That particular call,
your book combating cult
mind control, um, is, um,
right here it says number one
bestselling guide to protection,
rescue and recovery from
destructive cults is Judaism McCall.
So first let me just say that book first
came out in 1988 and it had a fellow on
the front cover who looked
a little bit like you but,
but clean shaven and he had a pad
lock and a chain around his forehead.
I hated it. I told the publisher I
hated it. They created the artwork,
did the artwork. And anyway,
it's been out for 25,
27 years now in hardback.
And
I've finally bought the rights back and
I've updated it post-internet including
terrorists and human trafficking and
including people born into cults like the
Jehovah's Witnesses. So that said, um,
I grew up in a conservative Jewish family,
the youngest of three.
My mom was an art teacher.
My Dad had a hardware store.
It as a musician before
that and after that, um,
and I really didn't like the
Judaism that I was taught,
but I was very close to my mom
and my maternal grandfather.
He was Orthodox and I grew up with
a spiritual feeling and connection.
I may still feel that connection and I'm
actually part of an alternative Jewish
community for the last 17 years.
But the,
the point that I want to say is that
there's a whole range and I actually gave
you a blow up of a graphic,
I don't know if you're going to use it,
but have ethical influence
and unethical influence.
And the idea is that one can look at
specific behavioral components and
determine whether or not it's a
destructive cult or a benign cult or
constructive cult.
So the word called in and of
itself tends to be pejorative,
but as someone who is quoted in the book
called the cult of Mac as a disciple,
uh, myself and the book, uh,
Max, yeah. Max Being Apple.
Yeah.
That was literally interviewed by this
writer who actually has a website called
the called the Mac. And he said,
your editor, my editor said,
I have to interview you. And I said, what
about writing a book about computers?
I said, that's weird. That's
not the typical interview. I go,
what's the title? He said, the
cult of Mac, and I laughed. I said,
I've been using apple since 1982
and a half, five Max right now,
but if you still want me to do an
interview, I'll be happy to do it.
I do believe that people, there are
certain people that are in a cult of Mac,
100% and I noticed it in the
90s when I was on Newsradio,
all the people on the staff, all the
people that work behind the scenes,
they would get so excited when a
new ios operating system came out,
apple s and they would talk about
it like we've got a new one now.
It's going to be better than windows.
It's going to be amazing. Yeah.
Science is a social science to
creating a called, but again,
I, I cite the bite model
and site that you know,
if there's deception,
so there's lack of informed consent.
If does extreme use of fear and guilt.
If there's information control where
people are being told you can't talk to
critics or or defectors or you need to
cut off from family or friends who are
questioning you. That's I'm, I'm
concerned about human rights.
I think the easiest way to understand
what I do as a former cult member myself,
it's really in support of the United
Nations Universal Declaration of human
rights,
not necessarily anti cult.
You are anti negative cults that have a
detrimental effect on a person's life.
Yeah,
and I would actually blow the frame up a
little bit bigger since I've been doing
this work for 39 years and I would say
I'm against undue influence. Undue.
How do you,
it's a legal term for exploitative
influence as compared to ethical influence
where it like a therapist is trying to
help somebody to confront their fears or
as a influence of helping somebody who
is addicted to something that's that's
killing them. When you put a lot
of religions in that category,
then that classification
of undue influence, right,
so the B you asked me is Judaism and halt.
The answer is there are
Jewish cults for sure.
And there are lots of other Jewish
temples and affiliations that are not
destructive cults.
So what would you consider them?
Them meaning the positive ones? I belong
to Temple Beth scion in Brookline,
Massachusetts. Brookline agree. My,
my rabbi wrote the Big Book of Jewish
humor and he was a comedian for most of
his adult career. He became
a rabbi later on, uh,
emotional wall docs and he cracks jokes
even during Yom Kippor and he's my kind
of rabbi.
It's not it,
it's gay friendly women's Center,
social justice.
But we love to sing. We left the chant.
We love to dive in. We love to do oven.
Davening is, is religious
prayer. Oh, okay.
Going through the side door and learning
toe or I love to go to tourist study.
It, it resonates for me, uh,
in terms of my spiritual path.
That said,
I've also studied Buddhism and I have
a teacher who was teaching me a Korean
form of meditation and movement.
He's a martial artists by the way.
Oh yeah. Korean martial arts
would kind, he's a swordsman.
Swordsman so it does like Kendo
or something, something like that.
The version of like the real sword thing.
Endo is a real art of sword and
they just use bamboo sticks.
We kind of know his Japanese
legs. Yes. Yeah. Um,
I learned a little bit of that in the
movies they would teach you in the moonies
Kendo really shiny.
It's nice to teach a little zone.
It's probably just in case they have to
take over the world and everybody's out
of, boy, I hope we have a chance to chat
about the moonies at some point we will
definitely call chat about
the moonies. So you, so you,
would you say your,
uh,
by doing this being involved in an
organized religion and ancient organized
religion in a sec that
you feel as positive,
would it be just more of a community
of philosophy and maybe just a,
a just a, a nice group
of people that, well,
it is a nice group of people.
Fans. We are independent,
although were influenced by the renewal
movement of Zalman Checked Shola me,
but we're trying to, what does that
mean? Where that's the name of a,
of a spiritual leader, a rabbi who
passed away who basically said, yeah,
and he liked to smoke pot. By
the way. I like him already.
He talked about like updating the
traditions for the modern time and that we
need,
the whole point is growth and
connection to other beings in a loving,
compassionate way.
It's not about being exclusive.
It's not about putting other
people down to be on your path.
It's about awareness and consciousness.
Well,
that sounds like a very
healthy perspective.
I don't think I would be part of a
spiritual community after everything I've
been through that wasn't super healthy
and giving me more than I was taking from
me. Are you allowed to eat bacon
in that group? People eat bacon.
I personally don't eat bacon. My
wife Loves Bacon, but uh, we're,
we're not. We drive to temple.
I live several miles away.
My rabbi drives to temp even
on Saturday on Shabbat. Whoa.
But you know, it's more important
to show up at temple then too,
you know, then to Miss
Temple, some mystical.
So the,
all of the carbs,
the rules should serve the spiritual
purpose and not the other way around that
these people are just compressed
into this rigidity, right,
of conformity and obedience and guilt
and shame that we are not into guilt and
shame. We're into joy and love and
laughter and helping one another.
That sounds very ideal. As far as
Cultco I, I think so. So it's a call.
It was just a really good
one. It's a good, um,
some people in Boston call it a cult
and I'm like, I'm a happily say,
I've been there for 17 years, from
the very beginning of his, uh,
his invitation to become a rabbi there.
And we've had our ups and downs, but
it's, it's healthy, it's accountable.
Uh, the membership make the agenda.
It's not tap top down, you know,
a dictatorship type thing.
It's the membership and a downs.
What's the downs?
Um,
there was some personality power conflicts
with teen and an assistant rabbi and
Moshe that was, um, other, you know,
just always how it works. So he's
some power struggle, you know,
human beings are imperfect.
And the key is,
is you know,
if somebody calls you on your shit that
you step back and you listen and you
reflect and you the correct your,
your your behavior or you don't.
And if you don't and you're,
and if you're a part of a community
like that in a leadership role,
then they ask you to leave.
And so that was what was going on there.
Uh,
in that particular case,
I think she wanted more say so she
didn't want to be the assistant rabbi.
I don't know all the checks be
rabbis. Oh yeah. We have, haven't,
we have an assistant rabbi right
now arrived. Claudia who is amazing.
And this is rob, like the form like
doc, I'm sorry. Yeah, it's like rabbi,
Rabbi means teacher is a female you call
rob or is it distinction for a male as
well? No, you can call a a
male, a Ralph also see this
weird to me that you were like an anti
cult guy, but this is clearly, um,
at the very least a very strong
ideology with some pretty rigid
sort of classifications of things.
Is that, is that fair to say?
I mean Judaism as the one that you yeah,
it seems to go here and we'll get
started. Nobody makes me, it's fine. Uh,
it's not the typical interview that
I'm asked to do, but then again,
I didn't expect us to be. What is
it? Well, it's not just conversation,
really try not to interview
people. Yeah. Okay. Um, for me,
I just want to grow and,
and I like being part of a
group that's bigger than myself,
particularly one that's interested in
helping Boston where members of the
Greater Boston interfaith organization
where we're fighting for justice to raise
minimum wage to help,
uh,
get rid of agregious banking
fees on immigrants. Um,
we bring in pro Palestinian
peace activists to speak.
We bring in,
um,
Steve Hassan to speak about costs to
all kinds of interesting programming.
And I love being part of a community.
And on a personal note,
when I had cancer nine years ago,
I had Hodgkin's lymphoma.
People were offering to drive me
to the hospital, make us meals,
and it was just great to feel like we
weren't alone facing that. That's great.
What I always hear from people that are
in Christian churches that really, uh,
really enjoy it.
They really enjoy the community and they
really enjoy the bond that they have
with all these folks.
And that it seems like coming together
and sitting together on Sunday or
whenever you do it and
worshiping that really, in fact,
part of what's going on there is you're
all making this sort of agreement to
look at the possibility of there being
a higher good for all of us and that you
all joined together in this and
then you get this, this bonding,
this feeling of community that we kinda
don't really have that much in this
world. A lot of folks don't
know their neighbors. They
don't, you know, they just,
I have a buddy lives in an apartment
building, it's like 50 floors.
He doesn't know a fucking single person
in the entire building. Yeah. I'm like,
that's so crazy and isolated.
Hundreds and hundreds of people.
You don't even know who they are.
Right. And that's part of what
needs to be changed in my opinion,
and make the world a healthier place
where people do know their neighbors and
they do offer our help. Uh,
if, if somebody needs help,
beauty of small towns,
the beauty of less people is
those people get appreciated more.
It's sort of like a,
you know,
you can have too much stuff and then that
stuff doesn't have any value anymore.
Or you can have one cherished
item that like, wow,
this is the baseball glove my dad gave
me when I was 10 and I will cherish it
forever instead of like a fucking
warehouse full of baseball gloves.
They don't mean Jack Shit to you.
And I think human beings are kind of
a warehouse full of baseball gloves.
It's just so many of us that it's,
we sort of lose value.
We'll lose an appreciation for us
because there's so many of them.
Uh, that's part of it. I
also think that, you know,
modern culture and civilization
and technology has created a,
uh, a false, um,
construct of what's
important and what's real,
where beingness and being part of a family
or a community or a tribe mattered as
a central theme of our identity.
Now it's consumerism and,
and what status you have at your job
or how much you're making or what car
you're driving and where
you're going on vacation.
And this information overload and sleep
deprivation that is very troubling.
Sleep deprivation. How so? Um,
it's probably one of the most studied
a phenomenon, the effects on the,
on the mind and on, um, on
the brain lack of sleep.
And it's one of the classic techniques
used by destructive cults by the way,
is sleep deprivation.
But if one analyzes American society,
my understanding is that the
average American is sleep deprived.
Isn't that one of the things that
Scientology supposedly does to those folks
that they have that work for pennies?
The, would they call them c Corp?
Uh, uh, it's the,
it's a C or c or billion year contract
billion. And that hilarious. You
signed a billion year contract.
Yeah. Um, and I want to
mention that I was part of a,
a five day seminar in Toronto a few weeks
ago called getting clear and some of
the top former officials of
Scientology were interviewed on stage.
I was on stage talking about hypnosis
cause Hubbard was a hypnotist and a lot of
the processes in Scientology or straight
out of a hypnosis textbook from the 20s
thirties which is when Hubbard was
reading about it, is like doing auditing.
Such a mean.
Yeah.
So to sit with your feet flat on the floor
and your hands in your lap and you're
closing your eyes and just being there.
Okay.
Not Reacting for 20 minutes. The
Scientologists will tell you, oh Joe,
you just licked your lips
or your knee quiver. No,
you've got to just free is for 20 minutes.
It's creating an altered state
of consciousness known as trance.
And I know we're going
to talk more about trans.
I'm sure there's nothing
wrong with trance states,
but when you're in a trance state,
you're more suggestible.
Someone who has authority and who has
an agenda to implant ideas in your head
because you're not in your critical
analytic part of your mind.
So just sitting for 20 minutes with your
hands in your lap and your feet flat
would lead you to be more
influenced by someone suggestions.
It's the first one.
The next one is sitting opposite
of Scientologists three feet away,
staring into the Scientologists
eyes for 20 minutes.
That's the next step.
That's the next one that Jamie,
it's really hot in here cause ac on out.
And the next one after that is bull
baiting where you have to stare straight
forward and the Scientologists tries
to get you to react or respond.
It's like a bowl with
a red k. Really? Yeah.
So they are training obedience.
There di Di desensitizing people from
normal social cues and interactions and
they're cultivating a compliant,
obedient trans identity
as a scientologist.
I didn't know that.
Just staring at someone just staring
into someone's eyes can create an altered
state of consciousness. Can, a
bunch of kids are going to race,
actually staring at it.
The candle staring at a spot on a wall
of it's known in hypnosis language as an
eye fixation technique is of very,
very common technique for inducing an
altered state of consciousness. Why?
Because the eyes are pretty
wired to move and scan.
And when you, and I should
also say hypnosis is not sleep.
It's an altered state of consciousness
that's the best characterized as
concentration or absorption.
And um,
and I just want to say one more time.
There's nothing wrong with that state.
I liked that state. I do self hypnosis.
I do meditation,
I do many different altered states,
uh, techniques. The
point is I'm in control.
I'm deciding I don't have somebody who's
alienating me from my own inner voice
and my own self and trying to imprint
me with an a totalistic ideology that's
black and white. US versus
them. Good versus evil.
So let's talk about you. You,
you got into the moonies that's,
and you were there for two years, is that
what it was? Yeah. Two and a half years.
Two and a half years.
And that led you to try to get a
greater understanding of cults,
the cult mind control and to help people.
What was your experience?
How old were you in 19
is that what you were
I was a,
I had skipped
eighth grade.
I was an extra honors student.
I was a creative writing major at
Queens College. Humblebrag see that?
Just kidding.
Um,
so you were an honest reading Plato
eight. I wasn't too Utopian
novels when I was nine,
but aside from that Copia novels,
it was,
I was wanting an ideal world and looking
around at what I saw in the media and
the Russians are going to nuke us.
And already I was sensitized to
global climate change way back then.
I was in the last draft lottery
to go to Vietnam. Anyway,
I had been basically dumped
by my girlfriend checks.
I do it every time and I was kind of
bummed and I was sitting in the cafeteria
waiting for my new semester to start and
three women pretending to be students
stress like students carrying books.
Like students asked if they can share my
table and they started asking me about
the books and I had from
students. No, they were moonies.
Wow.
And it was a deceptive systematic
at which I later learned how to do,
uh,
as a leader I learned how
to recruit people and um,
I had a similar situation,
college to do, you know me well,
there was this Italian class that I
was taking, it was just beautiful.
Puerto Rican girl, check
glasses. She's so hot. Ooh.
And she was always asking
me to go to these parties.
She's always inviting me to these
parties, like, come to this, come on,
go on to the Cape for the
weekend. You should come. And
I was like, whoa. Oh my God.
But I was always busy. I was
so mad. I was like, fuck,
I got to find a date where I was busy too.
I was a waiter on the weekends.
What year is this?
I graduated high school in [inaudible] 85.
Um, I took a year off before
I went to Umass Boston,
a wasted three years just
fucking around there. That was a,
so he was probably 86,
86, even Church of Christ,
I don't know what church they were in
because they were hot and heavy that
period of time, it could
be in Boston. They were,
they were inviting me to these retreats
and they had invited me to more than one
and I couldn't go what I was about.
I was still competing in martial arts
tournaments back then. I was always busy,
but I really liked this girl. She's
pretty hot and she's very friendly too.
I was like, wow, maybe she's
the one really friendly, loving,
cute severity. This is how it
goes down. Um, there was a,
an airplane crash in Boston and uh,
it was one of those weird
plane crashes where the, um,
did Trump have an airplane at one time
to Donald Trump have an airline? Maybe.
I don't know why we're connect
him to it and some strange way,
but whatever it was, this airline, um,
the way the wheels wouldn't come down,
you know how sometimes they make those
crazy landings where they skid across the
one way and the sparks fly and everything
like that. So I sat down with these, uh,
girls and, um, uh, we're at lunch
in the cafeteria and a, I go,
did you guys hear about the
plane crash? And they go, no,
what happened? And I said,
yeah, well some, uh, uh, the, the wheels
wouldn't, it was Trump airlines. Yeah,
that's what it was.
I'm pretty sure it was his,
you could probably find the actual
date that this happened. Finally,
actual date that Trump airlines, uh,
wheels wouldn't come down. So anyway,
it said Logan Airport in Boston, skids
parks, the whole might've been Boston,
it might've been somewhere else, but
I was living in Boston anyway. Boy,
am I getting off track these, uh, I,
I tell him the whole story then too,
by the way. So they go, what happened?
And I said, well, the wheels,
uh, didn't come down. And, uh,
they had a skate across the one way.
It was anyone hurt. I go, no, no,
no one was hurt. They go, oh, praise
God, praise God. And I just went, what?
It was just, it was weird. They all
clasp their hands together like this.
Praise God, pray. It wasn't like, wow,
whew, thank God nobody was hurt, you know,
which is like a normal expression.
But it was, it was a very pious,
like a devoutly religious praise God.
Oh praise God.
And I looked around, I go,
pray, okay, what do you guys do?
And then, and then I
started realizing, fuck man,
she didn't really want
me to come to a party.
Like there's something going on here and
save your soul man. Yeah. Well, and then,
and then I started asking him, I said to
you, you think God like saved that? Oh,
absolutely. I go, well, why didn't
God just make the wheels come down?
Why Freak everybody out? And
then quick question. And then,
and then it got weird and then it got
ugly and then they never talked to me
again. I forget where it
went. I was a dick back then.
I probably said something stupid.
Well, a lot of Bible Colts, uh,
Jewish Christian and
Muslim are into Armageddon.
You know,
the apocalypse is coming any moment.
It's a good way to get people to sign up.
Exactly.
The heavy pressure or scarcity
time's running out. If here, if,
if the world ended tomorrow,
are you ready or are you
going to hell for the rest?
Doesn't matter if it's ready or not. The
world's gonna end, you know, it's like,
are you ready to sign over your
real estate and your bonds?
And so you're sitting at this table,
these girls come over.
They weren't even students, right?
So what are they doing in school?
How do they get in? They lied. They
just walked in Shane's colleges,
city university, shitty security.
Probably can't do that. And not only that,
but later when I got
recruited into the group,
I was told to drop out of
Queens college from the cult,
sent back to Queens College to start a
student group on campus to get people
into the student groups so they would
drop out of Queens. College does adorable.
It's very slick. So you're sitting
there at this table, you're bummed out,
you're broken hearted. What was the girl
broke up with you? What was her name?
Let's call her Debbie fucking shoe is
a shoe model. That's all I remember.
Model. She had great legs and
I have no recollection of what
her name is. Oh, okay.
Let's call her Debbie.
So Debbie tears your heart apart and uh,
just leaves you there at this cafeteria
alone. Vulnerable. Poor Steve.
You're like,
what now what now?
I thought she was going to be the one
and these gals come over and where are
they hot?
They were cute and they were very
flirtatious. They didn't say, by the way,
masturbation is a sin and father's going
to line us up with thousands of people
in the sign.
Who's who you're gonna marry and you
have to wait four years to have sex with
them. Was that the moonies?
Yeah. How they do it? Yeah.
They didn't say anything about
that. Well, so I, and I said,
are you part of some religious
group? Oh No, not at all.
We just a group of students who
are concerned about modern issues.
What was their approach to you? They sat
down, they started talking to you. What,
what, what did they, what
are they open up with?
Hey, nice classes. Mm, no, I think I had,
it was the spring semester. I had a
pile of books, I was taking philosophy,
psychology, writing a, I
think I had to partner shots.
I think I had Heidegger's being
in time and they were like,
why being in time is that thick.
Oh Wow. You must be really smart.
Uh, what is, what is that about?
So they start flattering you serious?
Yeah.
The call is known and other
cults are known as love bombing.
You know, Puerto Rican girl did to
me too. Damn. She was hot steam.
It's all about saving the person's
soul and you know, step by step,
incremental recruitment,
finding out as much as you can about
the person saying almost nothing about
what you are about and what the
group is about. Well unlike you,
I wasn't particularly
vulnerable at the time,
so it was a good time for them to get
after me cause I was in the middle of some
pretty intense stuff. My lab, I
had a goal, I was pretty focused.
I wasn't get roped up in some religion,
but if they got me a couple of years
earlier I think they could have gotten me,
I was real vulnerable when I was like 18
so the,
the reality is as,
as human beings we have lifecycle events
where were situationally vulnerable,
death of a loved one, breakup
of a relationship. You know,
moving to a new city,
state or country illness,
there are things that every human
being goes through and for me is a
overwhelming ignorance of the
public to kind of blame the victims.
Like you were stupid for believing in
this. Like what was wrong with you?
You are a week for falling for this as
opposed to tell me about your experience
and tell me what you know,
what happened.
You know there's a principle in social
psychology called the fundamental
attribution error.
I know that so a of of syllables but it
basically is the single most important
principle of social psychology.
And when it means is what I
was basically saying before,
when people try to understand why
other people are doing what they do,
they over a tribute individual variables
and they under attribute social
environmental variables,
social environment variables are gigantic.
I think that's correct.
One of the things about a person
being older and wiser like that,
you always hear the
expression older and wiser,
but if you really look at it like
it mathematically, well what is it?
It's data.
It's accumulation of data and the
understanding of the relationships between
events, reactions and consequences.
And when you're 18 years old,
you don't have a lot of data, you only
have a few things that are going on.
And for, for me, when I was 18, it was a,
the breakup of me and this girl
that I was dating and the uh,
all of a sudden becoming a man,
being responsible,
having to go to college or get some sort
of a job or some sort of a career and
just the, just the overwhelming
possibilities of the future and,
and not having any clue as to what,
how it was all going to play out.
I was terrified.
And if someone came along with bright,
then I feel like they could have got me,
I feel like I was real
vulnerable around 18.
But I met this hot Puerto Rican girl, I
think I was about 20. And I was pretty,
I was pretty determined at
that time, so I was okay, but
well not said that there were so many
different types of destructive cults.
So they're not just all religious cults.
There can be a therapy called clinical
called can be a cult of personality.
That's very important.
That's very important because there's
a lot of different things that can lock
you in and then start to control you
and start to suck money off of you and
start to really dictate your
behavior in a very unhealthy way.
And that is so common.
There's so many different versions of it.
It almost seems to be like a pattern
of human behavior and thinking like a,
a code that you can kind of crack
like a cheat code and people.
Hmm.
We've experienced a revolution in science
and medicine and in psychology and in
particular social psychology.
There had been so many, you know,
pivotal experiments in the last 50 to
100 years that give us windows into
understanding our vulnerabilities.
So for example,
when I'm counseling someone who's
involved with a destructive cult,
I don't start out by saying,
hey, you're on a call,
let me liberate you or something.
In fact,
my whole approach is empowering
people to think for themselves.
So I asked them questions with respect
cause I really want them to think about
it. In any case, I showed them
the asch conformity study,
a Solomon Asch.
What does that the,
so the Solomon asch conformity
study was framed to people coming
into it as a visual perception experiment.
Basically,
they'd be brought into a room with several
people in a semicircle and there'll
be a person in the front with
a card with four lines on it,
a sample line, and then three
other lines of different sizes.
Okay,
let's say a three inch sample line,
a three inch or four inch and a five inch,
but everyone is in on the experiment
except the person and seat six.
And after going around twice
giving the correct answer,
everyone confidently starts
giving the wrong same answer.
And the test is how many people will
start to conform to giving the wrong
answer, even though they
can see what their own eyes,
what the correct answer is.
And that study's been
replicated thousands of times,
and the answer is two thirds start giving
the wrong answer even though they know
intellectually that it's the wrong answer
because it feels too uncomfortable to
be in the room. And is that the, the,
the testimony that they give when
they are asked, what did they shoot?
Assuming the interview these people
absolutely. Yeah, it's uncomfortable.
And I even show a dateline and old
dateline episode where they asked Anthony
Pratt, Kansas is one of the
foremost social psychologists to,
to actually do the studies so
they could film it. And this,
they start out with the
Asian woman who is the,
her role at resistor who
gives the correct answer,
but she's grimacing as she's
giving the wrong answer,
even though she knows
it's the right answer.
But because of the social forces we are,
have mirror neurons,
we want to fit in to the people in
the room. It's just human nature.
People survive. Exactly.
Clan behave. Exactly.
But it's hard wired.
So I show that video that,
that experiment and I always
like to ask people, so tell me a,
something you could do if you were in
that situation to scientifically reality
test that situation.
Scientifically Reality Test meaning
meaning what? You're in this room,
everyone's saying a five inch line is
a three in July. And what could you do?
Let me ask you, what would you do? Because
you have the data now. Okay, you're,
you're a cult expert. You would,
I'd get up and measure it. Right,
but you would obviously understand
what's going on. Right? Exactly.
But if you asked me prior to my induction
into the moonies that I understand the
asch conformity study or the power of B,
I would have said, no, I'm an individual.
I'm a nonconformist.
I had the bumper sticker
question authority and I had
the ponytail and you know
the word unique
right in you rebel.
Totally. So anyway, after
the asch conformity study,
the Milgram obedience study,
Stanley Milgrim did a test at the time,
the dominant
theory in psychology for explaining
how the Nazis good do what they did was
called the authoritarians personality.
And Milgram's said,
I wonder if Americans would
do the very same thing.
And he developed this ingenious shock box,
which really was set of switches.
I had no electricity at all,
but it sounded electrical.
And he basically would bring people and
tell them they're doing a scientific
experiment that's very important,
that tests memory and
punishment and learning and
set people up into a situation
where they thought they were giving
an electrical shock to the person,
the next room,
and it was all tape recorded with,
and it would increase 15 volts from mild
to moderate to severe to extreme to x,
x, x, x,
and there'd be a guy in a white lab coat
acting very proper who happened to be a
high school teacher who was
moonlighting a few extra bucks.
And the test was how many people would
electrocute of fellow human being in an
hour because an authority figure told
them they had to because they had made a
commitment to do a scientific experiment.
And the answer was two thirds.
Yeah,
I saw a regular lab listen
to a radio lab podcast on,
on that very thing.
It's,
it's in fact there's a movie that's coming
out about it called the experimenter.
And the next study that
I'm about to mention,
the movie just came out a week or two ago
called the Stanford prison experiment.
The fills for Barnardo. Yeah. Who was
one of my mentors trying to get it.
I was trying to get him on the podcast,
but I was out of the country when he
wanted to come on and I was really bummed
out. Well, try to get them back.
Yeah.
I'm going to fly in this amazing,
he taught a course at Stanford called
the psychology of mind control for 15
years and use two chapters of
my original book in it. Um,
and he was also president of the American
psychological association, but he,
so in his experiment he randomly divided
guys and to guards and prisoners and he
did basically controlled behavior,
information, thoughts and emotions.
And people started having nervous
breakdowns and some of the guards started
becoming sadistic. And instead
of saying, you know what,
I don't want to do the experiment anymore.
They had gotten so sucked
into the experience that they,
that they're only out was to
have a nervous breakdown. Wow.
It was extraordinary.
So when I'm helping people understand
what happens in the Scientology called the
Mooney called the TM cult,
or any number of other destructive cults,
I want them to,
what's a TM called? Transcendental
meditation. That's a cult. Oh yeah.
Really big time.
I thought that was just like a
method of like cleansing your mind.
I didn't know that there was even a coat
behind. Oh, my Rishi. She yogi. Oh yeah.
This is not,
I'm a,
people practice it.
They practice techniques of transcendental
meditation alone by themselves.
So they in a cult.
So,
uh,
the answer is you don't need to be in a
room with other people to be in a mind
control cult,
but it can get inside your head and
create a new cult identity that suppresses
your real identity and it's not healthy.
Well,
I have a very cursory understanding of
transcendental medication meditation.
So if you could please tell me
what exactly does that mean? So
cool.
Um,
and I have the story of a woman who was
raised in TM in chapter six of the new
book, Gina Catania. So, first of all,
there's a thousand or more ways to
meditate and there's not one way that
everyone has to meditate.
In fact, neurologically,
it's very detrimental for people to do,
for some people to do a mantra meditation
where they're repeating it over and
over,
it actually increases anxiety.
Really saw like Buddhist
meditations where they, oh,
so breath meditation. The
point is, is that it's a tool
for training consciousness.
And ultimately,
depending on your level of training,
you want to not be a victim of
your thoughts or your feelings.
You want to not only develop
a perspective and a wisdom,
uh,
consciousness.
You want to also get out of the entire
frame of self dialogue and just,
and total being this.
But any group that says you
have to do it our way or else,
or if you're having bad
reactions, they say, that's good.
You're unstressing keep doing it.
Yeah.
Is that what trends, denim
meditation? I'm afraid so. Well,
when you say bad reactions,
how so? Let's Hicks,
headaches,
um, barking like a dog.
I've heard from some, uh,
Jamie, who would that instating. Um,
there person go wrote a book about
TM and some of the net negative after
effects.
Um,
and what you need to understand about a
destructive cult is that that there are
many levels.
If you're just doing a meditation and
you're not doing the advanced than the
next advanced and then
becoming sell a bit and then,
oh,
that's all in transcendental meditation
goes.
And Maharishi was saying if we didn't,
if they didn't have 40,000 cities,
which meant people hopping around
thinking they were levitating,
that's hilarious.
The world would blow up.
So he was using the whole
fear trip thing to me,
raise a lot of money to get
people to be these devotions.
Yeah. This yogi flying.
It's is that, first of all,
how dare you? How dare you, this man,
these people are flying
and you're claiming bs.
You're very rare hopping on mattresses
today and they take a picture,
they're on the up, see, they're
flying. We've got the proof.
Someone is just like, you're poopooing
magic. Have you ever seen Jamie?
Have you seen it? Have you seen Yogi
flying? It's adorable. It's hilarious.
He's full. So I want to plug a
documentary. This here it goes. Yeah,
look at this. I mean,
no effort at all, right?
Phil Donahue actually edited
a show on this and it filled,
put his legs in Lotus and hopped.
Well, what's really funny is, wow,
I made amazing the Phil
can put his legs in Lotus,
but what's amazing is back when this
guy is getting tired, so his is hops.
Let's go back to the beginning.
Jamie.
His hops in the beginning were much
higher because he was fresh. Celia,
that kid's getting some air. Now let's
go a little bit further. Jamie, look,
good luck. See right there. He's
getting tired. I'm a fight commentator.
I understand what people are fatiguing.
It's guys getting lactic acid flying.
It's but my hurry. She said, you know,
this raises the energy level of the
planet earth so that there were fewer
automobile accident and less war.
I feel for all these people.
I really do.
I feel for that guy right there with
the classes in front of this cat because
he's fucked. All these
people, they're fucked.
It's like social anxiety,
lack of friends,
and a lack of community and there's
so many different things that can lead
someone to, to want to seek comfort
in these, these ideologies. And he's,
or they could have been born into it
or they could have been deceptively
recruited by a hot chick back to that guy.
But the the thing is,
is emotions.
If you're having doubts or if you're
having bad feelings, they're like,
it's telling you to like look at what's
happening and maybe you need to make a
change.
But if you're in the TM
movement and you're having
bad feelings about the group,
you're told that, that you need
to meditate to get rid of that.
And that's known as thought stopping.
That's one of the,
the techniques and the t of the bite and
model to shut down any reality testing
in the moonies.
We were taught to chance crush Satan
crush seat and crush Satan Rush,
Satan. It has a piece on
her. Gloria haven't of,
I want to tell you a true story.
Joe Rogan, but not be about Satan.
It is.
So I'm raised in a Jewish family.
We don't believe in Satan.
Okay. At all. You believe in God and the
Jewish family. Yeah. We'll wait a minute.
Hold on. If you believe in God, then you
have to believe in the god of the Bible.
Is that what you're defining goddess?
Now you're asking me to define
what I was believing as a child.
As a conservative Jew? Yes. I
guess so. The God of the Bible.
Isn't Satan in the Bible as well? No. No.
Satan is not in the Bible. No, not in the,
not in the toe run now.
Oh well that's a Torah.
That the new testament was a
invention later. Of course. Yeah.
Constantine. How many bishops,
right? Didn't he put it? 380?
I believe it was. Yeah. So, um,
here's the story.
So I'm in the Frickin Mooney's if
I may curse cause I've watched,
I don't think it was, is not
a curse. Okay, good. I don't
think you said a curse. Uh,
the exorcist movie comes out. Oh, buses,
300 members,
including myself into Greenwich village
to watch the exorcist hard watched the
movie.
We all get in our vans.
Go to Terry town to the palatial estate,
and they have a palatial estate they had.
They had multiple ones.
This one particular one, a Terry town is
where I got a lot of my indoctrination.
It used to be owned by the Seagram's
family. Moon gets up and he says,
God,
the exorcist,
this movie is a prophecy of what will
happen if people leave the unification
church. Okay? Now, before we,
before he gave that speech, we were
singing holy songs for three hours.
That's after watching this
crazy excersice movie.
And,
and I only remembered the exorcist movie
for years after I got out of the cult.
And I was studying psychology and
we were learning about phobias.
And I was thinking
back, well, so what was,
how was I installed with phobias?
And then I remembered this movie
and this lecture and it's like,
holy crap,
I believed it.
Hundred Percent Satan was everywhere.
And only by being in God's
holy family. Yep, that's it.
And the head zips around
and levitates movie.
It's scared suck though in any way.
So how can an intelligent person from
an intact family who is going to be a
professional writer and be a college
professor and get sucked into a cult that
wants to take over the world, make
an automatic theocracy, abolish,
say tannic democracy,
uh,
kill everyone that doesn't believe it
was literally what we were pretty much
told by moon that, you know, we
needed to reclaim the earth for God,
not unlike Isis and a few
other cults out there.
Um,
I was told the Holocaust was necessary
because the Jews didn't accept Jesus.
Well, I had been educated about
the Holocaust I'd been and what,
I didn't mention Israel to the
Holocaust museum. When you heard that,
what was your reaction?
I had been so,
so mine in the extreme cult
example is a dissociative disorder.
I'm speaking as a mental
health professional and Steve
has since on a Milton and
Estelle Hassan from flushing,
Queens became Steve Hassan,
son of some young moon and hock Jaha
and the true parents of the universe.
And he needed to be a clone
of moon and he was evil.
And my whole time in the group
was suppressing who I was.
It totally shutting
down any element of me.
I was sleeping three
to four hours a night.
I was working seven days a week for
no pay. I was recruiting people,
I was indoctrinating people, I
was doing political events, Ramon,
including fasting for Nixon during
the Watergate, fasting for Nixon,
fasting for Nixon because
God wanted him to be present.
That's how you know
you're in the wrong color.
So I'll tell you a quick funny story.
So my father voted for Nixon.
I voted for McGovern and we would,
my father was a business owner.
He thought Nixon was good. I said, daddy's
a cruck. How could you vote for him?
It's pathetic. I'm in the
cult. I call him up. I say,
dad were fasting for Nixon,
were in the capital,
and he says, Steven, you
are right. He's a crook.
I said, dad, you don't understand. God
wants Nixon to be president. He said,
now I know you're brainwashed.
He's a crook. I said, dad,
you just don't understand.
And how old were you at the time?
And this was when he was 19. 20. Yeah.
So I want to take it back to
the cafeteria if you don't mind.
So you sitting in this cafeteria,
these girls come up to you,
they start flattering you. They,
they, they're flirting with you. Um,
and then what's the next step?
So they're part of an international group
of students who are trying to make the
world a better place that happened to
have a house, kind of like a commune,
which was kind of interesting.
What I like to come over for dinner.
So it was the free dinner.
Would they cook?
I have no recollection.
And,
and it's interesting because back then
I was feeding them all the information
about myself, how I thought,
what my values were,
what my interests were.
So I was telling them
how to manipulate me.
You say in this day and age you can
go on the Internet and read people's
Facebooks and all of their posts
and you don't even need to ask them.
You say this. Right? But, um,
I'm assuming the girls you're talking
about are not much older than you, right?
So how would warrant them
being manipulated themselves?
Weren't they as essentially
a part of this whole thing?
And in that they were really
victims along the same way.
They were making you a victim.
Like they were bitten by the vampire
from victimizer model and they're called
identity is,
we're suppressing.
They were sent away from Japan,
from their family and friends,
and they were Japanese chess. They
were Japanese checks. Right, right.
That's what's up. So, but
here again, um, but they were,
we knew that they would have to
report each other if anyone deviated.
So that's why they would not
send people out individually,
like this tattle tale system.
But,
but my point being is if they were
not much older than you, if at all,
and they were also victims
of the same ideology,
call it whatever you want to call it,
the why would they be looking
to manipulate you? Oh,
wouldn't it be a part of it?
So members were taught to
believe as they still are, right.
And enlarge that the world is headlong
into an Armageddon situation of any
moment.
Judgment Day is happening.
And as much as you can to bring
people into God and save their soul.
Saving a person in the moonies meant
saving 10 generations of their father's
ancestors that are in the spirit world
and their mothers and sisters and less
feral world.
And they're all looking at you all the
time hoping you're going to make good
decisions because if you
do good things for God,
you're going to make good vitality
elements that will feed them in the spirit
world. And it got, I mean,
every culture has its own convoluted
yet internally a totalistic system.
So, but unlike Scientology, the
Mooneys or like save others,
Scientology is like, you know, become a
god and control everybody. Control matter,
energy, space and time and,
but we'll get people to do it.
You want them to do. Right.
But my point was that they,
these people were also manipulated, so
they knew that they were manipulating you,
but they didn't think that they
are being manipulated themselves.
But at the same call, I think they
were trying to find information.
When you're at fault Joe, you're not
having that reflection of, right.
You know, of course server
looking back and going, hey,
what just happened just
then is no medic commenting.
It's like your program to think
the right way, feel the right way,
act the right way. And
um, you're self censoring.
And in my particular case,
I guess because I'm somewhat
competitive on some level,
I know you have enough no relationship
to understanding what it feels like to be
competitive.
Uh,
I wanted to be the best Mooney I could
be chosen by moon and one of his right
hand people to be the
model leader in America.
So I was hand groomed to help take over
America and the world for two years.
So this had to be a very quick
transition from you, Steve Hassan,
normal college student to boom
full on fasting for Nixon.
Yeah.
I didn't mean it was very
fast.
It was about two weeks after
my first contact to me,
uh,
having what I thought was a spiritual
experience and believing that I was being
directed by God to this organization.
Wow. Yeah. So this madness
attribution happens a lot.
Now for some of my clients that literally
at a vulnerable point in their life,
maybe their religious in there praying,
Dear God tells me what to do. You know,
should I leave my marriage?
But you know, what should I do?
And the next thing they know the
doorbell is ringing and it's a Jehovah's
Witnesses who want to study the Bible
and they're like, miss attributing,
thinking God just rang the doorbell as
opposed to these people are going ringing
every single doorbell within a six block.
Great.
Of course it's like my friend Gary,
he hits on every girl he meets his
ideas that if you swing enough pitches
[inaudible] you never know you're
going to it. It's like he'll, he's,
he had some girls way hotter than him,
just way above his head and it
never works out. But he's like,
you just got to keep swinging. He didn't
have her know. I'm always hopeful. Yup.
So that's what they're dealing
with and winging it. Every pitch.
Essentially they're,
they're knocking on every door and every
now and then they get that one ball
that's in the strike zone.
And that Steve Hassan sitting there.
What does pile of books? Well, in my case,
so I went to this three day workshop.
I didn't want to stay, I was a
waiter on the weekends. I was busy.
I can't go on
on a weekend and they just kept saying,
it's going to be so great and Dah, Dah,
Dah.
I didn't even know it was a workshop.
And after two years of working at the
Holiday Inn in Hempstead as a banquet
waiter on the weekends,
I call up to find out when I'm supposed
to report it and he says, Steve,
you won't believe it, but the wedding
was canceled. So take the weekend off,
man. I had just had this,
these women working on me all
week. And I was like, well,
maybe I'm too, well, I did
give them my word because,
but I gave him my word thinking f is
never going to have a weekend off.
And then I was kind of like, well,
maybe I'm meant to go. I should do this.
So I say, I'm okay. I'm free
for the weekend. Let's go.
And we're driving up.
It's a middle of the winter through
this palatial estate. And they say,
by the way,
this weekend we're having a joint
workshop with the Unification Church.
And I said,
what church?
Nobody said anything
about church and workshop.
Nobody said anything about a workshop.
What's up with that?
And they did the typical, turn it around
on you. Technique of Steve, what's,
do you have issues with Christians to do?
You uh,
uh, you biased against Christians? And
all of a sudden, now I'm on the defensive,
but there were no cell
phones back then in 1974,
uh,
it's a middle of the night.
I have an option of getting out in
the snow and trying to hitchhike.
I'm like, what am I, well,
just wait for the morning.
Just stay here and we'll
drive you back in the morning.
And they slid around your bed like sirens
while I was in a room where I wasn't
sleeping.
Yeah.
So you've learned a little
hypnosis. The Joe, uh,
in any case, the morning comes, the
van is laughed. Now what? Um, you know,
and I fucked, well let's just go
in and, and see what you think.
And it was all orchestrated cause I later
learned how to orchestrate it and how
many people were in there with
you that were also new recruits.
So that was another trick,
a little bit of a scam because they had
people there that were acting like they
were newcomers but they weren't
creating small groups where
there's the illusion of,
so essentially a lot like the study
where they have the one those alerts and
it's not in on the study. There
was, it was very systematic. Wow.
And it get so good at that
with this Mooney character.
How did he create all this?
So we want the,
the long shorts, the shorts, real answer.
Okay. A background in science and
psychology or something. Sure.
I'm all so moon himself was
apparently in a cult and North Korea.
And it turns out that most cult
leaders were in a cult themselves.
So they didn't learn the
techniques out of thin air.
But the interesting thing about my
former cult was that the CIA set up the
Korean CIA because that had been two
coups in South Korea to that point.
And they were very worried about North
Korean brainwashing and they thought,
you know, we need to do something
to stabilize South Korea.
So they had this brilliant
idea of creating a private
group that would help to
reeducate political dissonance.
It's called victory over communism.
And I only know about this because there
was a Korea Gate investigation from 76
to 78,
um,
where the founder of the Korean ca
was interviewed and he said, he quote,
organized and utilize the Unification
Church for use as a political tool
unquote.
Wow.
And this was at the point where Americans
were getting fed up with Vietnam
wanting us to withdraw.
The hawks were very worried about and
like needing a stronger stance against
communism. So they thought, oh yeah,
we need to have student groups on
campus saying we need to have a military
response to communists.
We should be in Vietnam.
And the moonies we use for that too later.
I was part of the fasting for Nixon thing.
There was a whole political,
very shady piece here.
So you go from this,
you get out. How did you get out? How'd
you figure out that? It was all bad.
I was rescued by my family essentially.
Uh,
they didn't know where I was for a year.
I drove into the back of a tractor trailer
truck on the Baltimore Beltway at 80
miles an hour in intro
and basically nearly died.
Broke my leg really badly,
fall asleep on the wheel or something.
Fell asleep three days,
no sleep and two weeks
in the hospital sleeping,
eating away from the group.
I missed my sister Thea,
who was the only person in my previous
life that didn't say I was in a cult or
brainwashed. She was always just like,
I love you and I don't understand,
this doesn't seem like you Steve.
I reached out to her not because I wanted
to leave but cause I missed her and
she was like,
you have two nephews.
I want them to know they were uncle
Steve Come and visit. And I'm like,
if you promise not to tell the parents,
I can arrange it because I'm
a leader and she promised.
And fortunately she broke her promise
and she told my parents and they hired
some x members and they did a
deprogramming intervention with me.
Ex members of the moonies. Yeah. Wow.
So your parents went deep with this.
They knew what they were dealing with.
They put everything on the table because
they knew they could have gone to jail
too if it didn't work. One of the, one
of the team was a woman I had recruited,
could have gotten the jail. Yeah. Why?
Because it's illegal to abduct and adult.
In my case,
I just took my crutches away.
I had a cast from my toes to
my groin abduction. Correct.
But uh, at the point that I said I want
to leave and they wouldn't let me leave,
I could have been something
about false imprisonment.
But the long and the short of it is,
is I was so confident that what I was
doing was correct and that I wasn't
brainwashed and at a critical
juncture where we were,
they were moving locations cause the
cult was coming after me to rescue me.
My father's weeped,
she just started crying and said,
what would you do if it
was your son who quit?
You dropped out of school,
quit his job and during his bank account
and got involved with a controversial
group,
how would you feel?
And he was crying and I never saw my
father cry and it just touched the real me
and I could,
I build my cult self thought he was
brainwashed by the communist media against
spot there.
But the real me was like,
dad really loves me and I want to
prove to him that I'm not brainwashed.
So I said, what do you
want me to do? He said,
I just want you to talk with
them for another four days.
Like having an open mind
and if you want to go back,
at least your mother and I
will be able to sleep at night.
Knowing we did the
responsible thing and I agreed
and I had this days
where they were teaching me about thought
reform in the psychology of totalism,
which was a book by Robert J lift and
about Chinese Communist brainwashing of
the fifties I had all of these experiences
that we're starting to surface that
had been suppressed at
during my leadership.
It's the same mechanism that
allows people to be inspired,
the same mechanism that allows
people to be manipulated.
You know that man mechanism
being you see something that's,
there's something about it that
makes you excited, like, like a,
a great performance,
a great concert or an athletic
performance we get out of,
they just feel inspired. A great book
that inspires you at manipulates your,
your brainwaves,
manipulates your consciousness and it
steers you in a certain direction is that
same sort of mechanism that allows
people to be influenced by others.
What allows people to be manipulated
by others in this form where you can
actually literally change the way
they think and view the world.
That's a big piece of it.
Is it sort of a law in the,
the beautiful thing about inspiration?
Is it a flaw in that?
Because inspiration is
beautiful. It's fuel, right?
Well, I think you need to have the
analytic part of your mind, right? And a,
and a consciousness that just because
it sounds great and looks great,
doesn't mean that it isn't
great. But you know what I'm saying? Like,
you know how sometimes things happen
and you're just carried away by them.
Like you go see a movie and you're like,
God damn, I just want to go do something.
I just feel so good. He's just like,
he got you. You know? Do you ever,
do you see Braveheart? I have. I saw
brave heart man for like two hours.
I wanted a sword fight. After that
movie was over, I wanted to join.
I'm like fruit. Um, you know, it's like
there's, there's those mine grow up
with watching combat on TV and just,
you know,
and I not see and yeah,
I really wanted to fight.
What I'm trying to get at is there's,
when you see things and when information
and data gets into your mind,
it influences you in this very strange
way that can be positive and it can be
inspirational.
Like whether it's seeing Michael Jordan
put on an incredible formats or Rhonda
Rousey, you know, beating
someone or you know, those,
those moments where someone does
something truly great, it's fuel. For you,
its fuel.
Is that the same sort of mechanism that
they kind of tap into to change your
mind?
Definitely. It's, it's a piece of the
emotional and the brain stimulation.
So it's like the hack your mind.
It's kind of like hacking.
I talk about in the book the via like
a virus that gets in and corrupts your
operating system. You still
have your original one, but the,
now this malware has been
inserted and now you're working,
you think that it's you,
but I thought it was Steve,
just the true Steve and that the
old Steve was the fall and Steve.
But stepping back and getting perspective
and seeing the patterns of mind
control and manipulation in other groups.
And then reflecting
back on your own experience is the one
of the basic tenants of what I do in my,
in my work,
helping family members to rescue loved
ones are helping people who are either
born in a cult or recruited into a call.
So in a sense that this,
this experience that you had when you
were 19 was incredibly beneficial for your
career. Ah, yeah. Um,
I have mixed emotions when I hear
you say that, cause I didn't,
I don't want to do this work
to be completely honest.
Really, really, really.
You don't want it because you don't want
it to be work that it would be done.
It's traumatic.
It's helping people who are suffering,
but don't you get a benefit out of that?
I get,
I get a fulfillment that I'm doing
something really helpful to individuals.
I'm trying to help people around the
world to understand this phenomenon.
I'm trying to counter some of the
major forces against totalitarianism,
but to suggest that,
you know, wow, you know,
you have the moonies to thank for Korea.
Oh,
I'm saying it's beneficial for
you having a negative experience.
You don't have anyone. So it's, it's, it's
a wounded healer model. Yes, yes, yes.
It definitely deepened to me in a way
that I could not have been deep before
because when you wake up from being
in a group like this, the shame,
the embarrassment,
that confusion,
I felt like I didn't know who I was.
I didn't know what was real.
I literally had to have my family and
my friends show me videos of who I was
before to remind me,
wow,
what I needed to go to places that I
used to go to. Like I had a belief,
and this is very common and I want
to touch on Stefan Molyneux, uh,
which is how I learned about you
seeing your interview with him. But,
um,
I believed I had an abused childhood.
It was part of how they
conditioned this new cult identity,
suppress my old identity as they poisoned
me against my past and what coded
everything. So what did they tell
you happened about your childhood?
It wasn't that someone stood
over me and told me, but it was,
it was part of the whole
indoctrination system,
listening to other people, talking about
abuses in their families, et cetera.
But I literally, when I first got out
of the group, I thought I was miserable,
depressed,
that my father was physically abusive.
And when I said to my sister while dad
was physically abusive, she went, what?
You really thought it? Yes. Wow. Yes.
But what you have an actual image in
your mind of your father doing it.
So one real memory that
everything else was built off of.
And it was an actual event that happened.
I think I was 11 or 12.
My father wanted to know where the
change was for lunch and I had bought
baseball cards or something and I
lied and my father slapped my face.
That was the one true. And that
was the one time my father had me.
Um, but I really believed
it and my sisters were like,
dad never hit us because his father beat
the crap out of him. He never, you know,
that that's issue wasn't,
you didn't want to hug us or hold us,
but that was not physically abusive.
So just one moment where
he lost his patient. Yeah.
Formed false memories based on that.
Right.
And what what Scientology does is
they have you go back and, and,
and remember abuse from the past,
but then once you're done
remembering whatever,
then you go into your past
lives to remember all the
abuse. That's where it's really, and
it keeps going on and on, don't they?
When they're doing that
and that auditing process,
aren't they trying to get you to let
it go? Like isn't the idea that you,
you were repeat a traumatic event so
many times that it means nothing to like,
like if you've ever been around
someone who doesn't swear,
like you're your grandma or something like
that and she says, fuck you. Like Whoa,
what the hell?
Like your grandma doesn't swear,
but if you're around one like Jamie,
this kid's got a total potty mouth.
It just comes flying out of him.
You know what I mean?
Like if you're around certain people,
they swear all the time, it seems normal.
And in the word lose its meaning.
It just becomes a part
of the normal vernacular.
But if you're around someone
and it's very, very, very rare,
it becomes like this,
this big moment. Well,
the idea being that you repeat this thing,
this event over and over and over and
over again, so it loses its meaning,
it loses its impact.
So is that what they do?
So that there's a qualitative difference?
We'll change the sensitization
around a word or something.
And actually trauma processing harbored
was using a very old model of Catharsis
that you have to remember the abuse and
you have to reexperience the abuse over
and over and over again.
And that's been thrown out by the
mental health profession decades ago.
Why?
Because you're,
you're revictimizing people having them
suffer the experience over and over and
over again. If I want to help someone
who's been abused, I tell them,
you have to be in your body in the
here and now, and you have, uh,
a window or a TV screen seeing
the younger you, but you're safe.
You're here.
The abuse happened over there and I don't
want them to have associated memories
of abuse.
I want them to know that they're safe,
that that did happen. But it's not, it's,
it's just incorrect to think the,
the brain and the emotions are battery
and all you need to do is drain it and
then it's gone.
It's just not,
isn't a,
but it doesn't work.
These theories about how to
approach a various past traumas,
traumatic incidents, these theories
are a, essentially a variable, right?
Like what work work with one person
might not necessarily work with another
person. And a lot of these ideas
that you put into practice,
I mean, don't they? I mean,
aren't there flexible?
There have been therapy colts.
We were open this up by talking about
different types of cults and if any
ideology that's black and white in
that you're trying to compress human
experience into the ideology is
worrisome because no one model is,
is true. Everyone's different,
everyone's different. But the,
the goal as a therapist is do no harm
and empower the person to be functional,
right?
It's the goal isn't to trauma process.
So in the last few years I've been trained
in a form of attachment therapy where
we're people,
people who have personality disorders,
which were hitherto,
um,
believe to be like permanent can
actually be cured in two to three years.
And the technique is basically using
hypnotherapy technique where you're asking
the person to go back to a key traumatic
moment in their childhood and imagining
asking them to imagine if they had the
ideal mother or the IDL father that was
uniquely suited to them and they did
exactly what you wanted them to do in that
situation and ask their
imagination to fill in the scene.
You do it, you, you,
the person literally can create a
positive reference point of safety,
of security, of love,
of a tea, of connection,
all the things that children
need to experience to have
a sense of how a healthy
sense of self and people
know that they were abused,
but they're repairenting to use another
term there internally using their
imagination,
their repairenting themselves.
And what we is now proven
neuroscientifically is there's, there's,
um,
neurogenesis and neuroplasticity to the
point where people can know that they
were abused,
remember it,
but they can act as if they
had that healthy mother and
their healthy father and
a healthy childhood.
Yeah.
And be functional. It doesn't not
seem to know it works. It works.
It works.
Act as if they believe,
I mean this sounds like fantasy.
Am I reading it wrong?
MMM. So, well,
it's interesting for me to
hear you frame it like that.
People are not coming out of a therapy
like that thinking that they had a great
childhood. Right. But they're
no longer walking around,
bleeding all over the place.
Afraid to trust somebody. Uh,
having self
doubt, unable to touch and have
sexual contact. That's, that's,
that feels good because they've created
these reference experiential states from
themselves.
Now these reference experiential
states that they create these,
these theories and these practices of
therapy that someone has to invent these.
Like someone has to look at the problems,
you have to figure out what's the best
way to approach these things and come up
with an idea and hope that it works.
And as you said,
there's like the l Ron Hubbard
methods that he was using that he,
that were really ancient,
those they thought that was
going to work and it didn't work.
Yeah. And he was never a
medical health professional,
but he was arrested for practicing
medicine without a license.
And they did call it a religion to try to
right in the birthday. But this,
these, these ideas, they're,
they're essentially,
people come up with ideas of how to
treat people that have various elements,
right. They, they, they, and they, and
then they apply them to people. I mean,
how do they practice this stuff? I mean,
this is not like something like, hmm,
I need to figure out how
to chop this tree down. Oh,
I'm going to try to invent an acts like
in, in what I'm saying. In my case,
I was out of the cult for four
years when I first, um, um,
so a, a formal hypnotist
do a trance on somebody.
And my reaction was I used to do
that when I was doing lectures.
Like I had no awareness that I had
been taught to do hypnotic methods.
I was told to model the older brothers
and it was kind of a behavioral modeling
kind of thing.
And I started wanting to learn hypnosis.
I wanted to understand what it was,
what it was and how to do it ethically.
And essentially there has been a lot of
trial and error and a lot of people have
gotten hurt by the misuse of it.
But if you're in a professional
organization with as a
strict code of ethics
where there are clear boundaries and
people can trust that you're there just to
help them and they have, it's
not about keeping you as a, as a,
as a client forever.
It's like the faster you can get out
of treatment and just live your life,
the happier the therapist is. And the
more you can teach the person about how,
how to know themselves and how to
control their feelings or control their
thoughts,
et cetera.
The better what is happening right now
in Europe because the socialized medicine
is,
they really are testing a lot of these
approaches and demonstrating that people,
for example,
with narcissistic personality disorder
actually get cured after two to three
years.
But coming back to my work, when
I was, when I was first doing
this work and I was uh, uh,
struck by people who is saying,
but you are recruited at 19,
you had an identity before
I was born into the group.
I don't have a pre called self.
What do I do?
I didn't know what to say to them
other than make one up. Right,
and they started doing
that now 39 years later.
It's actually a treatment modality and
I'm not, I'm not taking credit for it.
I'm just saying
a successful,
happy,
positive childhood free of this
ridiculous confining ideal.
It's like if, if you're, if you're
real life is this story
line you're making,
he's making some create an alternate one
spaces fingers as a as a default where
instead of a parent beating beating you
when you're asking for help or saying
you're being a sissy, but you have
someone saying, tell me what's wrong,
let you know you need a hug,
and they're visualizing that and feeling
like there's someone who's really there
for them. That's an anchor.
That's a good role model for them.
It really can enable them at the point
that they're parenting their children to
not just reenact the, the, the,
the modeling that they learned and beat
the crap out of their kid but actually
behave like a healthy person would.
[inaudible] it seems to me
that it's beautiful that
all these theories are being
developed and tested
and applied its beauty,
but it seems to me like it's all a
work in progress. Is that an incorrect,
like it's not like there's any hard fast
method for definitely curing people of
weird psychological ailments
are caught like thinking. I,
I think where I think the
human species is evolving,
I think we're very at a very low
level of evolution in terms of our
understanding of things. However, um,
people are able to get out of the most
horrendous abusive childhoods and be
functional and not just commit suicide
or be drug addicts would be psychotic and
a mental ward,
but they're able to function and in
what we're learning about the brain is,
is, is just wonderful. I'm excited
about the future in terms of that.
That said,
there's a huge potential for abuse.
Now you technique by you saying that
you don't like doing it and it's just,
is it just because it's too taxing on you?
It's,
or is it because you really wish that
this wasn't something that you really
needed to do? Correct,
right. Yeah, I mean,
we can all sort of empathize with that.
I mean,
of course anybody who has children will
look at, uh, you love your children.
You look at people who were
abused as children are abused by,
especially by their parents. And it's
just this unbelievably painful thing to,
to here in,
forget about witness or be a part of,
but to hear about someone being beaten
by their parents or f, you know,
abused in some sort of a way.
I had my friend Barry Crimmins
on the podcast yesterday,
a great standup comedian from Boston,
and he has a new movie that's out today.
It's called call me lucky that,
uh,
Bob Goldthwait directed
and it's about his, uh,
he was raped when he was four by his
babysitters boyfriend. They would,
you know, multiple times. And this
is horrible, horrible, horrible,
traumatic story and a big
part of his life as his,
his perseverance and overcoming this
thing that happened to him when he's four.
He's 62 years old now. Right.
You know what I mean? This,
this trauma has sort of like defined
him in some ways and strengthened him.
And other ways that he, his,
his ability to overcome it,
showing his perseverance but fuck
right.
And,
and often people who have been
suffering a trauma like that,
if they become comedians,
they're compensating to
try and balance the pain
and maybe call it members.
Right.
Because that would be someone who'd be
vulnerable for someone who, you know,
would have some reaching for a
utopian view of the world or some,
some better way. Cause you
know, the horror of the abuse.
Yeah. So a lot truth is, is that the, the,
the bigger cults don't want people who
are seriously emotionally disturbed
because they can't control them.
If they're serious,
seriously disturbed.
They don't want them.
You want your money,
but they don't want you on staff and
they don't want to to be part of the PR.
So did the, Oh, okay. So do they have
like hierarchies like say a funeral, Lee.
So have you joined Scientology or
something like that? Here's your book.
I'll show you that if you,
uh,
if you go to Scientology and they did
give you one of those personality tests,
which I took by the way,
it's hilarious.
They make you hold on these Folgers
coffee cans. And this is the pyramid,
right?
So if you're in the CR gear in
the upper quadrant of the pyramid,
the leader Tom Cruise, you're in the
fringe. He's a friend. She's not a leader.
I think he's a leader. I think you're
wrong. I think you got a metal dude.
He did gold metal. Yeah.
But he's, he's not staff.
He's more like a symbol and it gives tons
of money and he's good for recruiting,
but he's not running the group.
What do you think's going on with that?
You think he's gay?
Uh,
uh, I've yet to hear an
argument against it by,
I would say John Travolta.
Apparently it's by John's
gay and he's buy toms by. Uh,
that's my impression.
But I have not heard from any farmer
Scientologists through just accept being
gay. Would Scientology go away
immediately? Well, that's homophobic.
It's totally homophobic.
Moonies oh yeah.
It's a degraded human being.
If you're gay. In fact,
cupboard San Quintin was gay and
he killed himself all his murder.
So when you saw going clear,
were you happy that, um, uh, I'm,
I'm in the middle of the book right now.
It's God damn amazing.
It's amazing when you go over l Ron
Hubbard pass and how absolutely ridiculous
it was, how many times he lied about
things, all the nonsense. And he said,
and all the different times he was caught
lying and all the different people in
his life that he would just make up crazy
stories about being this world war two
hero was God.
He was blind and he's completely crazy.
Completely crazy.
It's amazing that a guy that's that
damaged could get that many people to buy
his nonsense.
And it is.
So, um, Larry, right?
And Hbo did a documentary based on that.
Yes, Larry, right? Janet, right man,
they all took their material from my
friend John a tech who was a former member
OT five who wrote a book called a piece
of blue sky and John and put together
this, this, uh, conference in
Toronto called getting clear.
The website's getting clear.co
and we debunked not only Hubbard,
but the entire policies
inside the organization.
I was explaining mind control and
it's going to be made live on,
on the Internet that people
can watch while this,
the reason that he did this and why I
encouraged him to do this was people were
leaving David Miscavige's
Church of Scientology but
starting their own splinter
group of Scientology where they were still
idolizing Hubbard and still doing the
tech and we wanted it to bunk the
whole thing from start to finish.
And I think it was done very masterfully.
Okay.
So they were starting like subgroups
where they came up with their own stuff.
They would do it. They
were taking, they were on
well automatic pilot of all these
[inaudible] closer up to your face. Yeah,
I, yeah, sorry about that. No
worries. Um, so for example,
the number two man, number three, man,
Marty Rathbun and Mike Rinder had left
the group and we're spelling all the
secrets of what, you know, all the
criminal activities that were being done.
They were creating independence
Scientologists and trying
to keep doing auditing
and keep doing the processing. And
it's like, dude, come on, like wake up.
The whole system was
warped and weird and like,
so they were trying,
were they trying to like find some
beneficial aspects of what they had based
most of their life on?
Is that what it was?
Were trying to salvage some of it right,
but like there,
if to use the cult identity thing,
they're called identity was trying
to re, you know, Redo things
that Miscavige guys a trip.
[inaudible] listen to him talk and those
conversations and especially that giant
speech that he gave,
you know when they got tax
free status,
like wow,
that was a really good book by
Tony Ortega who has the blog.
If anyone listening wants to know about
Scientology, it's Tony or take it out.
Or he wrote a book called the unbreakable
miss, lovely about Paulette Cooper,
who was a friend of mine when I left the
moonies in 1976 she wrote a book called
the scandal of Scientology.
And the book is all about her life story
and how this group harassed the hell
out of her Scientology.
Yes.
Because she told the truth about
Hubbard and and the organization,
and Hubbard said, never
defend, always attack,
and they did all these criminal
activities systematically,
which still goes on to this day.
So wait,
I'm having a book release party after
this and you're invited if you want to
meet some of the people in
the going clear handle it. I,
I'm too busy today.
No worries.
You're doing something at the sea
bound theater. Yes. Tomorrow night,
the Steve Allen Theater on Steve Allen,
by the way,
son was in a cult for 11 years and I,
he was a big supporter.
I watched you on the Steve Allen show.
That was one of the first
things I saw of you.
He was a substitute hosts on CNN back in
[inaudible] 88 when the book first came
out and he gave me a big plug and I loved,
I love him for it and how I get to be
at the theater named after him talking
about the book again.
But the new edition and these days I'm
particularly focused on helping victims
of pimps and traffickers,
pimps and traffickers,
sort of a form of a cult in
some ways is a commercial cult.
They, they do all the bite model, the
behavior control, information, control,
thought, control, emotional control,
make people over and to a new identity
and they are dependent and obedient.
And I've code developed a curriculum to
help survivors to you in the game to get
to stand because that's what
pimps call what they do the game.
So to basically understand that they
don't love the women in their stable,
that their products and for exploitation.
And the only way to win the game is
to end it and get out and have a life.
It's fascinating that you equate
those cause it makes sense.
But I've never done it before.
I've never put it in my head and thought
of a pimp and a prostitute being like
the pimp runs a cult. So, um,
if you read some of the
manuals online by pimps,
how to brainwash the hose
there terminology for women.
I actually tell the story in
chapter six of Rachel Thomas,
who was recruited while she
was in junior at Emory college.
She's a beautiful black woman and she was
recruited by a pimp who basically said,
you're beautiful. You should be a
model. I want to take your picture,
put you in some rap music videos,
which he did.
And then he started beating her up and,
and,
and farming her out for sex and
threatening to kill her family if she told
anybody. Fortunately she turns
to the FBI, he's in jail,
she's doing a project to help young girls.
And we've codevelop this
cause she read my book,
she said that this really
helps me to understand how
he did it to me.
Have you ever seen those documentaries,
like pimps up hoes down or Americans?
Yes. Yeah, that's a big part of it.
As they would talk about how they would
find people that came from broken homes
or they've had daddy issues and they
would foster this feeling of family.
Right, right. Well, and the, the, the,
the cult that I was most experienced
with helping victims of was a cult called
the children of God. Uh, which
the leader was Moses, David Berg,
and he was a pedophile and he had to
leave the u s cause he was gonna be
arrested.
And he in his,
in his culty had women be
happy hookers for Jesus.
And he basically told people they
had to have sex with, with, uh,
two year olds, three year olds, four
year olds. So it was a sex cult.
And when people would be either
kicked out of that coal or run away,
my theory is that pimps found
them on the streets and,
and started learning from them,
but the religious terminology that family,
et Cetera.
Um,
and uh,
so the sex trafficking and then the
other thing that is occupying a lot of
people's consciousnesses, terrorist
cults like Isis, Boko Haram,
which are trafficking women by the way.
Um,
and they're taking not just
weak, uh, stupid people. But,
uh,
for example,
the one of the architects of Isis as
social media recruiting that work was the
son of a, of a endocrinologist
at mass general hospital.
Someone who has raised in Boston,
went to a Catholic high school.
And unfortunately or fortunately he was
killed by a drone strike few months ago,
this kid.
But my heart goes out to them,
you know,
people who get deceptively recruited in
mind controlled cause it happened to me
and if I hadn't been deprogrammed I could
have done horrible acts of violence.
So that's how I was trained.
Wow. So they were training you to
sword fight, you said? Yeah, they,
they basically trained me
hi or kill on command.
And they trained me that if I allowed
a doubt when I was given an order by my
superior that Satan was going to
be invading me, I'll exorcist.
And so, you know, whatever
I was told to do, I dead.
It's incredibly frightening.
What literally when I saw the,
the, the body's down a Jones town,
my first thought was I
could have done that.
And when I saw the planes going into
the World Trade Center, I thought, yeah,
I could have done that too.
That's part of my passion and what
propels me so many years later because the
problem hasn't gone away.
It's gotten worse.
Have documentaries like going clear
the HBO documentary, has that helped?
Definitely.
It's been great.
My Gripe about his book
and the documentary is that
it didn't deal at all with
mind control or brainwashing.
It didn't give anyone who was watching
the documentary or reading the book tools
for how to protect themselves or if
they were in a cult to self reflect and
analyze what was happening.
He's only got enough time to just fill
an hour and a half or whatever it was,
two hours, but there's so
much. So my Rand's Joe,
when when, when Wright's book first
came out, I did a short video ramp.
I said saying going clear
as the definitive book on
Scientology is like saying
you've written a definitive book on
cars and leaving out guests combustion
engines. That was what I
said. So I was frustrated.
In other words, cause yeah, brilliant.
People like Paul Haggis who has incredible
how they would career saying I was
stupid for believing this for 30 years
and giving so much money to them and what
has happened. He's not stupid.
What has happened to those guys?
They being attacked.
The,
the group has changed dramatically
because of former leaders coming out and
speaking out.
The group.
Anonymous helped a lot initially by
harmful now homeless by wearing masks and
saying, come on, let's protest.
It scared them and it created
a culture where people were,
we're more empowered to speak
out against them right now.
We want the tax exemption to be stripped.
There's no reason we should be subsidizing
a group that's paying millions of
dollars to harass form.
Remember,
that was one of the most
disturbing aspects of the
movie when you find out that
they, how they achieve tax exempt
status by a litany of lawsuits, right?
They propelled against the IRS and also
hiring pis to dig up dirt on the IRS
commissioners and hiring
powerful lobbyists and a,
it's dirty. The whole thing is
dirty. Just seems too easy. Like,
how can they be so easily influenced to
give these mean I have to do is read one
of his fucking books, right? And you go,
this guy, this guy wrote Scientology,
the guy real battlefield earth
like fucking Christ. Right? So,
but the bottom line is that if,
if there's a total list group that
has a black and white us versus them,
good versus evil,
simplistic ideology that says that,
um,
you know,
we have the vision for the world
has to be a, we have the tools.
So how to be the best person you can be.
One needs to operate with some
consumer awareness and say,
who is this person? Why did his
background, is he trustworthy,
end whatever it is,
seek critics and x members
and know that if it's true,
it will stand up to scrutiny. And if
it isn't, you know, if it isn't true,
why would you want to invest your
time and your energy and your money in
something that's not real?
People would just searching for meaning.
I mean that's what a lot of this is
all us searching for,
meaning to make their life a better.
Well that's how the suck
you in, right? I mean, they suck you
in with dianetics. When I was, uh,
living in California for
the first time in 94, uh,
there was no internet or I hadn't
been on you and it was just,
it was just starting to get on. I think
I might've gotten a computer around then.
I, there was a late night
television commercial for
dianetics and of the volcano.
Remember the volcano
of course be the OT three story is
he knew when the galactic kicked
dictatorship.
Yeah. Well the, the volcano
just looked like, you know,
unleashing your potential to me, like,
yes. Dianetics powerful. I had, you know,
listen to some Anthony Robbins books on
tape and I was ready to rock and roll.
You know,
I was trying to stop it
studying.
He was studying Ericsson and an LP
and that is basically covert hypnotic.
Can you have a happier
marriage in 1989 page one 11.
How can you have more job satisfaction
in 1989? Page two 27. Yeah,
this was the commercial. So
I, uh, I bought the book.
I ordered it online.
I don't even remember how I pay it.
I guess I had a credit card.
Um,
and these fucking people would
not stop sending me things. Right.
I mean, for years, like every week or
so, every month or so, whatever it was,
I would get something in the mail
inviting me to this, inviting me to that.
I mean,
it was just amazing how persistent
counted as one of the 8 million followers,
even though there's really 20,000 or less.
I was a follower.
So somewhere your name.
Exactly. Am I in a database?
Dianetics member or title?
So I'm on my end.
Scientology it was I at one point in
time, no. Well, how would I counted then?
Uh, because they, cults
like to fudge statistics.
They're much bigger than they really are.
So what is the actual number
of Scientologists number
that my friends tell me?
It's 20,000 or less. That's not
that many in the world. That's it.
Yeah. So how do they have so much real
estate? They have billions of dollars.
They've sucked a lot of wealthy
people dry. That's incredible. Yeah.
Paul Haggis paid a shit load of money.
Right.
That's one of the things you talked about.
Yup.
Hubbard was into money and power.
Let me empower sex.
It's the three Universal's with
all destructive cults. Yeah.
Like the Waco thing. Right. They always
want to have sex with everybody. His wife.
Um, yeah. Power money. Uh,
interestingly I met the,
I met Byron sage last December.
Who is the lead FBI negotiator
with David Koresh at Waco.
Is he the guy that sent the tanks
in to burn everybody out here?
I'm afraid so, or somebody that
you're going to negotiate the FBI? No,
he was, he was clearly, um,
unhappy and he more or less said that
we didn't know what we were doing and we
wish that you had, you know,
we had known what to do.
He was clearly unhappy with the result.
He, he knew that they screwed up.
Well that's a nice way of saying
they murdered a bunch of people
cause that's what they
did. The videos, well,
they should never have gone established.
You know,
they should never have gone in
with guns in the first place.
The David Koresh was molesting
minors and they were, you know,
making automatic weapons but the lord
him into town and arrested him and they
could have taken away the guns and
they were sure that he molested minors.
Oh yeah.
How old were the miners?
It's hen
very,
Joel
testified before Congress. It
was one of his victims. But, um,
I just,
I guess because of the,
I want to come back to how I
learned about you and, and, and,
and your good work with Stephin.
Mala knew if I may and free domain radio,
that was,
you could say good work.
It's just a conversation where
I asked him some questions,
but it helped a lot of members wake up
because they respect you and they got to
listen to their divine leader lie,
you know,
and, and it was powerful
to hear him say, oh no,
I don't tell people the Dfo,
I always tell people to go to therapists
before they cut off from all their
family and friends.
And people knew that
that was a blatant lie.
And it took a chink out of the mysticism
of people who were true believers
because you held your own with
him. You know, he didn't, you know,
wrap you around his finger as he's used
to doing with the followers and their
respect for you. So I, I, my hat's off.
It wasn't my intention.
My intention was just to
have a conversation with
them and trying to figure out
what he's doing or what
his thought process is.
He's got some really good ideas about
things. It's, it's fascinating. He's,
he's a very eloquent guy and
he's very smart, obviously,
and he has some really
interesting concepts,
but he's very firm in his belief
about certain things as well,
to the point where you're like, one of
the things that I talked to him about,
we played a video of him
yelling about someone,
if you believe in the state that you
want him killed, you want me killed,
and that you should get rid of all of
your friends that believe in the state,
you know, and this idea of a narco
capitalism, her kids, and like you,
you don't want any government whatsoever.
Like who's going to fix the streets?
So there was, and there was no answers
to those whose going to pay for anything,
who's going to, who's going to
organize, where were, what do you,
how are you going to like,
this is not like a well thought out thing.
This is like this someone,
someone said it best that he's an
incredibly eloquent man that is screaming
north while pretending
to be holding a camera
bus. That's interesting. While
he's another one of those,
you know,
and like corporations,
while he's owning a corporation
type people and you know,
saying that he's liberating people and
he's in fact enslaving people into a
totalistic belief system.
Do you think that he's,
do you think this is just something
that sort of happened along the way?
Like as he was, you know, I
honestly having his philosophy and
I don't know enough about him,
I was hired by a family to consult to
help a young man who was getting sucked in
and they were worried about that.
He would try to cut off contact.
And fortunately he's okay.
So it was a relatively new phenomenon
for me but was particularly interesting
about this particular call was that he
was recruiting over over the Internet and
that's how isis is largely recruiting
as well. So it was an interesting,
well you say recruiting though.
How has he, how he recruit,
he just does videos where he
kind of talks about his ideas.
Right?
Right.
And he gets followers to tell other
people to watch the videos and they watch
for hours and hours and hours and they,
it,
they re he rewires their thought processes
to the point where he gets them to
question their own belief systems,
their own value systems.
And because he's a bully and he's a loud
mouth and he talks so confidently about
a lot of things that he doesn't
really know very well. What play,
we talked a little bit before about Robin
Williams and that has just one small
example.
Yeah. The Robin Williams
one really disturbed me.
It's one of the things that I questioned
him on because he said that he believed
that Robin Williams,
he made a video.
We're saying that Rob Williams killed
himself because of all the women that
we're addicted to. Free Shit I
think is the way he described it,
that these women who were addicted
to getting money from him,
they sucked him dry.
Robin and I had the same agent and he was
worth millions of dollars when he died.
He was not broken any way,
shape or form.
He certainly was diminishing in his
ability or is it ability to earn money was
diminishing as he was getting older, but
that's just normal for actors. Right.
You know, he, he was,
he had real depression and he also
had Parkinson's and the Parkinson's
medication that he was on, one of the
side effects was severe depression.
Uh, also, um, there's a good friend
of mine, Dr. Mark Gordon, who had,
he's done a lot of work, uh, people
with traumatic brain injuries.
He wrote a paper on, um,
uh, surgery and how, uh,
people who have undergone a large,
very traumatic surgeries like bro Robin
when had open heart surgery oftentimes
experience postsurgery depression and
that it's a physiological response to your
body being under an anesthesia for long
periods of time plus the physical trauma
of the actual surgery itself, the injury
and you know, your body's healing.
And especially as you're older,
that is a massive task to heal a heart
that has been cut open and stitched up
and your, your chest plate has been
spread apart. It's very traumatic,
physically traumatic,
and that oftentimes can lead to a
diminished a state of consciousness.
And then depression sets and also the
reality of mortality sets in on a lot of
people.
So I was upset at that because I just
didn't understand why he would do that,
but I didn't,
I didn't have that conversation with him,
like trying to expose him.
I had that conversation with him,
just ask him questions and
then after it was over,
that's when all these
videos started coming out.
And that's when I realized that he was
deceptive about a few things in the
conversation.
Yeah.
It was initially fantasizing that you
would invite him back and I would be here
and then some families who have been cut
off from their loved one would be here
and we could be like, you know, dude,
tell all your followers to get a therapist
and reconnect with their families.
Like if you really care,
like do something.
Yeah.
The diff,
the defunding thing was one of the
things that he swing his family of origin
after hello family aboard. And He, uh,
apparently is fond of
telling certain people to,
uh,
got rid of all of his followers. And not
just your family though, your friends,
your childhood friends that have
nothing to do with your family. He,
because he wants people not to have other
influences in their life that can say,
hey dude,
do you think this is conscious?
Do you think this is a conscious thing
or do you think this is a natural state
of someone trying to achieve power?
What do you mean what, what is,
what is the mechanism behind that?
I, um, I don't know
about him specifically.
I would say most cult leaders are
not cold calculating con artists,
they're delusional.
They often were victims of mind control
themselves and are kind of playing out
of, uh, an identification with
the aggressor type scenario.
Uh, I don't know enough about
him to comment intelligently,
but for me it's about wanting people
to reclaim their personal power.
And I want to say to anyone who's involved
with Molyneux who may be listening to
this is take, take time out, step back,
learn about mind control, learn
about cults, talk to former leaders,
talked to former members,
reflect over your own experience.
Ask yourself what, when you were first
getting involved with mile and a,
what did you think you were getting into
when you were first getting involved?
Did you believe you were
going to be cutting off from
your family, your friends,
your life, dropping out of school,
turning over your trust funds?
And if the answer was
turning over your trust,
when who's turning over your money,
what do you mean? And what,
what, who's turning over money?
I can't quote a particular person,
but that's the pattern with
all these groups as if they
know that you have money,
they want it.
Yeah.
But as far as I know more than you,
he's not asking people to give them
all their money. He's not doing that.
He's not asking people to
turn over their trust fund.
He might ask for like small donations,
but I don't think it's fair to say
that he's asking people to turn over.
I don't want to misspeak.
So if you are sure about that.
Yeah, I've never heard of that.
I've never heard that accusation.
But what my impression from him when
I first met him was that he's very
intelligent and oftentimes
very intelligent people
are frustrated by really
stupid people that are around them.
And when he has solutions for particular,
particular issues that are in society
or particular behavior patterns,
he speaks about them very
confidently and people, uh,
become enthralled with that. And then I
think that's a very addictive process.
The addictive process
of offering solutions,
having people praise
you for those solutions.
And then having people come to you for
advice and sometimes you get ahead of
yourself.
You just see this momentum in that and
sometimes you get in front of the wheel
and you can't stop it and then you're
just spouting off about everything.
Like he would do these videos, the truth
about this or the truth about that.
The truth about people that died and
you're talking about like people that had
very complex lives,
they lived a hundred years or whatever
the fuck they lived and the you,
you can't just boil that down into
one video with very little research,
especially when you're doing a hundred
of their videos a week and you're doing
all these interviews and doing podcasts
and doing all these things that you,
you're talking about someone's life,
man.
You can't see the truth about Lincoln
unless you fucking study Lincoln for a
long period of time.
And even then,
like Dan Carlin is my favorite historian,
doesn't even call himself in the story,
but as, as a podcaster, he's brilliant
in his podcast, hardcore history.
One of the best things about it,
he will offer opposing points of view.
He will say, some people believe
that this is what happens. There's,
there's some dispute about this because
it seems to be there just certain
schools of thought about why this took
place. I think that's super important.
So whenever he starts saying the
truth about something like, man,
that you're just, you just
can't do that, you know?
And that's why the truth about
Robin Williams as a person,
as a professional stand up comedian,
right.
It was particularly offensive to me
cause I'm like, come on man, you know,
you're talking about this beloved
guy who had this incredibly complex
relationship just with his ex wives,
but with show business, with life,
with depression,
with drugs.
Like this is not something you can just
boil down to a one hour podcast or a one
hour youtube video and just
called the truth about someone.
Right? So I want to mention
there's a retired, uh,
child protective agency,
social worker named David Cooperson,
who wrote a book about corporal punishment
because that's one of a Mala news
claims, et cetera. And,
and cooperson has studied a number of
vol new videos and the whole ideology,
and he's written a great book by the way,
it's on a stop legal child.
abuse.com is David's website and he
just more or less says as someone who's
worked with children who've
been traumatized, whether
it was beaten by their,
their parents or their foster
parents are sexually abused.
The best thing is not to cut off
contact with the abuse of family.
It's to have therapists and to have
a healthy frame to work within it.
And not just to impose from the outside
or by some authority figure who says
that they know what's better for them.
Because even kids who are being abused
still have feelings towards their mother
or father that are positive because
of the way we're wired. So anyway,
I wanted to get a plugin for
his book and the fact that,
and then I wanted to mention Molly
Kotch, Molly be Kotch k o c h. Dot.
Com wrote a book on parenting called
27 secrets to raising amazing children.
And she too,
when I asked her to comment as an expert
on parenting about what [inaudible] was
saying with saying,
this is not going to help people
to be healthier human beings,
to cuddle off contact from family and
friends no matter what happened in their
childhood.
But the best thing is with therapy
and ideally with a family therapist to
approach it to the extent that people,
uh,
are protected so they're not further
abused by their family of origin.
Well, this seems very black and white
to me because if you're coming from an,
an incredibly abusive family and your,
your,
your family was brutal and they beat
you and I did horrible things to you,
which I know people who've come from
cutting them off is a great idea.
I disagree. Really. So you think if your
father sexually abused you, rapes you,
beats you up, it comes home and an
alcoholic rage and breaks your skull,
you should still call that guy.
I didn't say that, but what do you
mean if that, if you're in that area.
But if you're in that scenario,
um,
I'm saying you should be in therapy if
that's happened to you and your therapist
should,
should consider,
depending on the course of treatment
approaching the f the father or the mother
and getting them into therapy,
maybe they need to get off of alcohol or
drugs or maybe they they need therapy.
But just cutting off your
entire background and past
as a chop it off for me is
really not a healthy long term solution.
But not even saying cutting
off your entire past.
I'm saying don't have contact with someone
who was horrible to you. You don't.
So what,
what I'm trying to say Joe,
as a therapist and I've
seen these situations,
I'm also involved with parental alienation
cases where there's a divorce and the
custodial parent brainwashers the
children against the father or the mother,
which is horrendous. People can
grow, keep people can change,
people can evolve and
whatever is on.
Also there's false memory syndrome
where people were getting in with, uh,
not good therapists or using hypnosis
or getting into cults and being like,
I was believing I had
this horrible childhood.
Just cutting off and saying I can't ever
talk with them again is not a healthy
choice in my opinion.
Being being with an ethical therapist
and finding a way to who evaluate what's
happening with them and getting them
into treatment and then PR potentially to
have some type of family therapy
situation if it's not going to be helpful
ultimately, then of course don't,
don't reach victimize yourself.
Don't allow yourself to continue
to be abused. But this kind of,
this notion of lopping off your
father, your mother, your sister,
your brother because they were Shitty
to you 20 years ago or 40 years ago,
I think is a mistake as a therapist.
Do you, you think it's a mistake
across the board? I do, but what it,
but there are gotta be scenarios where
you shouldn't be hanging out with your
brother because your brother used to
rape you or your brother used to beat me.
[inaudible] I'm not talking about
hanging out and communicating with them.
Why have any contact with someone who
horribly abused you were just because
their family would you
do that to a friend?
So this idea that blood and DNA somehow
or another make you inexorably connected
to some person that was
horribly abusive to you.
If you had a friend that you
grew up with and your friend,
he's to rape you and
beat the fuck out of you.
You supposed to still contact them
because they were your friend and they'll
always be in your life.
Uh, I think a friend who raped me, uh,
is a different category than a father.
A brother, a sister, a brother. Well,
how's it different? Um,
cause it's bloody right.
Yes. That seems crazy. Family seems like
ape thinking. That's like monkey thinking.
That doesn't even make any
sense. Well, I mean if someone,
if someone was horribly abusive to you
and they're an evil person and we both
agree that there are evil people in
the world, right? Yeah. Someone was
evil to you 30 years ago. The question
is, are they still evil today?
Why?
Find out
why not? Cause he's not enough time.
The if a hundred years, if you're lucky,
you know,
I mean if you,
if you want to really try to fix someone
who raped you and beat you up most of
your childhood or would
you rather just move on?
Oh,
who are like raising the children of God
and they were raped by their brothers
and sisters and fathers and mothers and
they want to have a healthy relationship
with their children because they realize
that's the past that's not now and that
they were doing the best they could under
those circumstances because that's how
they were indoctrinated to be.
But this is a different thing
you're talking about people having,
you just said people having a
relationship with their own children.
You're not talking about people that the
people that raped them and abused them.
You're not talking about people having
a relationship with those people.
So, for example, I mean, when
they were in, for example,
a cult,
like the children of God,
they weren't thinking that their father
and mother were raping them and their
aunt and their uncle raping it, but
they were having abusive sex, right?
That was not something that they were
ready for or wanted it to have and it hurt
and et cetera.
Now they're out and for me
to just say, look, you know,
cut off all contact and,
and assume there's no possibility
that they could grow. They can change,
they can evolve, they can apologize, they
can make it up to you. For me, that's,
that's not the ideal.
It's not what my,
my position as a healer,
as someone who's worked with
so many other people now,
and I'm not saying is if you've been
hurt by someone to just call them up and
then have them hurt you,
that's, I'm not saying that.
I'm saying use professionals as mediators
to see what's possible in terms of
constructive,
healthy change.
But you're,
you're,
you're putting this in this family context
and this is where it confuses me like
that. You should do that
because they're your family,
but you shouldn't do that
if they were your friend.
No,
I'm not.
I guess I'm not meaning to
sound so absolute and every
case should be evaluated
individually, but I, I do have,
I guess I've had too many cases where
it was this kind of total cuddle off.
Right.
I see what you're saying
and maybe it's justified,
but maybe it's not. Maybe
the person really, you know,
got great therapy and they are incredibly
remorseful and they want to apologize
and there are a decent human being.
You can keep carrying the
pain and the judgment and say,
I'll know I'll never talk with you again.
Or try to accept them for where they
are now and see whether or not they're
going to be beneficial to your ongoing.
It shouldn't the onus be on
the person who victimize you.
If someone raped you and beat you,
shouldn't the onus be on them to come
and apologize to you or attempt to
apologize to you?
I got to spray them out and bring them
to therapy and try to hash it out with
them.
I would agree with that.
Yeah, I would agree with that.
I think everyone ultimately has to take
responsibility for their own lives and
their own actions.
I mean,
I felt terrible for a lot of the
things that I did in the Mooney is,
and I did best to reach out to
people I had recruited who I,
whose lives I had interfered with and,
and it was a burden for many,
many years. As long as they continue to
be in the group and they're all out now.
But virtually no one
wants to talk with me.
I think they still harbor
really bad feelings towards me.
Wow. That's gotta be so strange for you
to be in the position that you're in now,
to have these people that look at
you as someone who victimize them.
And the very way you're trying
to shield people from today.
[inaudible]
so the, that's probably flavoring
this idea that you're, you know,
you want people to always try to hash it
out or work it out because of your own
personal experiences. Well, let, I think
people can grow and people can change.
They can or they cannot write.
But also stagger them and advocate
for change. I am too, but I'm also,
I also believe there's some people that
are just beyond fucked up and there's
nothing you can do about them and
it's not a bad idea to cut them off.
I know I have their parents off and
they're very happy because of it,
because their parents were evil and the
parents are fucked up. I mean, and there,
every time they would be with them or
communicate with them would just be
incredibly damaging and they would have
to deal with it for months on end and
the stress and the pain,
we're just not worth it.
And ultimately they felt better to,
you know,
to forgive that person but
not communicate with them.
See, here's where we differ. Uh,
I guess if I have more of the Jewish
angle on forgiveness,
like I don't believe in forgiving people,
don't apologize and don't
offer compensation and
don't promise never to do it
again and then never do it again.
That's kind of the Jewish formula and
only then is the person who was wrong in a
position to forgive.
But I'm not of the thing of just forgive.
But I,
I guess I,
I think ultimately the more
sense of fullness of wholeness,
of knowing that we do everything
that's within our power,
our sphere of influence to
do, to be a good person, to,
to bring goodness to the
planet is the way to operate.
And I think that for
me, with my father, he,
he didn't beat me, but he didn't
hug me. He didn't, you know,
give me a lot of praise when I was growing
up because his father never gave him
that. And instead of at
the, when I was in therapy,
instead of being angry at him,
he neve under stepping
into his shoes as a child,
realizing he was doing the best
that he could. And at 30 I just,
when I saw him,
I just started hugging him and
he'd be like a board and I'd be,
I just say s stand there
because I need a hug.
And by the time he was in his eighties,
he was actually wanting the hug and he
50 years.
Yeah.
Yeah. It took 50 years. It actually
said, I love you. And I'm proud of you.
He died at 92 but I got
to see my father evolve.
And what is the big difference between
that and someone would beat the shit out
of you and raped you.
That's a lot of people's reality when
you're dealing with their parents. I mean,
your dad doesn't sound abusive. He just
sounded like he's the victim of his own.
He wasn't abusive and I had a
relatively normal cha, you know,
boring in many ways cause they
didn't smoke. They didn't drink,
they didn't have affairs.
I lived in the same house.
That wasn't like moving all over the,
you know, it wasn't a child of divorce.
But I guess I want to just come
back to everyone needs to kind of
be in touch with their inner voice,
their inner intuition and instead of
holding of frozen frame in their mind of
what happened 30 years ago
and just keeping that, eh,
I can't be with him because of that.
Find out what's going on.
And I'm not saying put yourself in
a position where you can be harmed,
but you can use third parties to find
out what's going on there and there could
be some really radical
positive changes that happen.
That could be a really good thing.
I see here
in up to a certain degree,
there's a certain degree of abuse that
I think some parents have enacted on
their children.
There was a story that someone told me
recently about this brother that was
raping his sister and the,
you know,
this went on for years and then the dad
found out about it and the dad joined in
and this went on for more years.
Those people can both go fuck themselves.
If I was that girl and if I knew
that girl, I would tell them to,
I would tell him never, never
contact them, never talked
to them. There's no need.
You don't. Just because they're your
blood, that doesn't mean anything.
It's nonsense. Your family, you know,
you can have family
that's not related to you.
The people that you love and trust and
if you treat them like they are family,
they'll treat you like family too.
I think you choose the people that you
can be in contact with and that's the
problem that a lot of people have with
this whole idea of family is that you're
born into them. You don't, it's like just,
you just get a random hand
of cards, right? You know,
and that's your family and you just
have to accept that for the rest of your
life.
And then when they fuck up,
you have to keep trying to forgive them
or help them or bring them together or
not.
I say not say with certain people like
that girl whose brother and dad raped
her. This no fucking need to
bring those people into your life.
If you can get away from them, stay away
from them. Hopefully they're in jail. Now.
I don't know what happened
in that particular situation,
but I grew up with a father that beat
the fuck out of my mother and I saw it a
bunch of times when I was little and
I was five years old.
And my mom laughed.
So these images are very old
and they're very distorted,
but there are 100% real. There's, there's
certain things that were undeniable,
the physical abuse, and I have had no
desire to talk to that person ever since,
and I don't ever want to,
I don't need it. You know,
this idea of blood that this,
because this person had sex with my mom
and made me that I have to forgive this
dummy and spend time with them and try
to work out why beat the fuck out of my
mom in front of me. I don't need
that. And I don't think that,
I don't think you need that to heal
and grow. I don't think it's necessary
and I'm not imposing my
point of view on you.
I'm just sharing my point of view as a
therapist who's seen literally hundreds
and hundreds of different
cases and people can change.
I also want to go,
come back to the false memory point
because there's a lot of people who went
into therapy or they got into a cult and
they came to have the belief that are
in a satanic cult. They were beaten
and tortured by, by their family.
And it's not true,
but there's still acting as if it is.
And there's no effort to reality test
to actually talk to the siblings or talk
with the neighbors or see if there's a,
most sexual predators
have multiple victims.
They're usually not just enacting
on one particular person.
Um, and what I've been saying
from the beginning is, you know,
find a good therapist who's experienced
with trauma and sexual abuse and such,
and,
and do it to your process and consider,
and especially if there's anyone listening
who's a follower of Stefan Molyneux
who's cut off contact with their brothers
and their sisters and their mothers.
Is this an epidemic?
I think there are a hundreds really.
I think there were hundreds and I'm just
saying, take a timeout from Molyneux.
Stop listening to his
podcasts for a few weeks.
Learn about mind control. Learn
about cults. Read the book. I, I,
I watched a video that was put on line
by a follower of Molyneux who was,
you know, had just left and I, I
reached out to him. I said, I've,
I've got free videos on my freedom
of mind website. Check out my book.
And he just emailed me literally yesterday
was this morning saying, you know,
it's given me a new understanding
about everything. Thank you so much.
And,
and if you have cut off contact
for years and years and years,
find someone to reach out to your
family and create a way pack.
Because a lot of people are afraid to
even reach out and they're confused still
because they're like Israel.
Yeah.
I've had some people who've
left Scientology, for example,
come to me because they many years of
being in the call didn't go to mom when
she was dying in the hospital.
They didn't go to their brother's wedding
and they were supposed to be the best
man. What? They borrowed money over and
over and over again. The families like,
screw you, we never want to hear from
you again. Now that person's woken up,
they've left Scientology and nobody in
the family wants anything to do with them.
And I feel like I at least should make
an effort to say to them, you know,
there is such a thing as mine control and
they were doing what they thought they
were supposed to do.
I being in the cult and you know
you were right to be angry at them,
for not being there for mom and
for not being there. However,
that doesn't mean that they're bad,
bad people and that there isn't
some value and reconnecting. Again,
it was one of the more disturbing parts
of going clear was seeing the people
that were just emotionally devastated by
the fact their family wouldn't talk to
them anymore because they
had been excommunicated.
Right. So this disconnection, the
JW is call it this fellow shipping.
It's a common mind control
technique to manipulate people,
to cut them off from family and friends.
If people are breaking no rules
or questioning the authority,
et Cetera,
it's not something that should be
done by any legitimate religion.
Certainly not any,
any legitimate organization telling
people you can't talk to your sister,
your brother, your mother,
your father, because some,
some authority figure
says God doesn't want it,
or that you've violated the rules.
Well,
either they're taking it to another level
right there saying you can't talk to
them because it's against
the rules to talk to them.
They're not encouraging the fooling,
you know,
getting rid of your family
of original origin. They're
there. They're encouraging.
They're saying there's no rule. There's
a rule. I mean, it's not encouraging.
They're there. They're actually
saying like, you can't talk to them.
Right?
And if you do talk with them,
then you risk being kicked
out of the group too. Right?
That's the threat. Now, one of the
things about mind control cults is,
um,
like I was shown the exorcist,
if I was going to leave the
moonies part of my unconscious,
saw that little girl with the et cetera
in the mind of someone on the mind
control,
they can't visualize themselves out of
the group being happy and fulfilled.
And, and in the mind of Scientologists,
if you leave, you're going to go insane.
You're going to commit suicide,
you're going to become a
drug addict is no possible.
And they put phobia's a member's minds
against any mental health professional.
So if you're feeling suicidal,
if you are having major Migraines,
only do auditing only do
Scientology techniques.
And at the point that I think it
was Paul Haggis that you know,
we refuse to, you know,
refute his gay daughter when,
when he learned that Scientology came
out against the bill in California at
that,
that was his wake up call because his
love for his daughter trumped the cult
ideology.
How bizarre is that?
That Scientology has an
anti homosexual ideas?
I think it's very bizarre, but a
lot of cults are very anti, but why?
What is, what does Hubbard
was a homophobe, is that what
it is? Yeah. Yeah. Probably.
He had sexual drives towards
men that he couldn't deal with,
so he decided to make a rule and
make it into a horrible thing.
So how does it fit with a guy like
John Travolta who's allegedly gay?
That seems so bizarre.
It's,
it's incredibly horrible because
essentially you can't eat it.
The cult.
The cult identity does not
want to acknowledge the
person's true self and every
time he acts out his true nature,
he feels bad.
But the speculation is that
they have some dirt on him.
The speculation is that through the
auditing process or the files they keep on
you, that was what they implied in the
documentary that they have these stacks of
files on
and they do massages, folders, et cetera.
They send that in the Time
magazine cover story in 1990. Uh,
there's a huge amount of fear and threat
that if you leave the group or speak
out against the group, they're going
to come after you and ruin your life.
And unfortunately a lot of people have
fear and for me and other people who've
left, you kind of have to rise
above it and say, screw you,
I'm not going to live like that.
We're scrolling towel,
whatever you want to tell that screw you.
For certain people though that
the ideology of Scientology,
the, the, the, the,
the tenants or the,
you know,
the principals seem to help them give
them some sort of structure. I mean,
is there any way that there's anything
beneficial to like the way they,
I mean there's a lot of successful people
that are Scientologists and they seem
like ambitious and motivated.
It seems like there's part of it,
and I'm not trying to support Scientology,
but I'm trying to look at this
in a balanced perspective.
It seems like at least some of what
they're doing is trying to enhance your
ability to function as a
person, right? Is that not true?
Uh, they say one thing and
what they do as another thing,
they say that they're going to give you
power over your mind and your body over
matter and are joining a clean space.
But a lot of it comes down to the belief
that's programmed into the Scientology
identity.
That you have this higher truth that
you understand the nature of reality,
that a certain technique is going to work.
But what we know from the placebo effect,
the power of authority and the power
of suggestion is what's happening here.
It's not the techniques itself,
it's not the ideology.
And also the,
the,
the feeling of being empowered by
being a part of a successful group,
a successful group,
and the motivation that they give you.
You got a buggy. Yeah, it's pretty late.
[inaudible] five 30 and this half an hour
ago. Your bladder's talking. Go ahead.
And then there's a bathroom right over
there and we'll just wrap this up.
Then I'll, I'll tell everybody.
All right. That's, uh,
we're going to wrap this up here,
combating cult mind control,
Steve Assan and you can get
a hold of Steve on Twitter.
His Twitter handle is,
hold on one second. Hall.
It is a cult expert at
cult expert on Twitter.
Um,
so Nate and conversation,
I don't know if I agree
with him on everything, but,
but obviously a very knowledgeable guy
and a very nice guy. So, uh, that's a,
that's a wrap. You fucks. We'll be
back tomorrow. That's right. Bitches.
The fight companion returns tomorrow.
7:00 PM Pacific Time. Eddie Bravo.
Brennan shot. Brian Cowen, the full
vote, goddammit. And
it'll be fun. All right,
we'll see you soon. Much love. Bye. Bye.